thousands of light years from Earth
there could be another planet hospitable
to life
Kepler 69c
and you're about to travel to this alien
world to see that life with your own
eyes
what would it be like to make this Epic
Journey so far across the universe
what kind of planet would you be likely
to find upon arrival
and if you did discover Life what would
it look like
this is what if and here's what would
happen if there's life on Kepler 69c
located 2 383 light years from Earth in
the cygnus constellation is a potential
super Earth
at least that's what it's often referred
to as Kepler 69c is an exoplanet about
1.7 times larger than our planet
and it could also be around three and a
half times more massive
but there's a catch
we don't really know if this planet is
located within the habitable zone of its
star
if it's too close Kepler 69c would be
too hot for liquid water to exist on its
surface if it's too far from its Sun
well then it would be nothing more than
a frigid world
what we do know is that Kepler 69c
orbits its star about 40 percent closer
than Earth orbits the Sun and that could
mean that it isn't actually a super
Earth
it could be a super Venus
so if you traveled all the way here
would you find life
or a thick scorching atmosphere boiling
every drop of water on the planet
before you begin your journey to Kepler
69c there'd be one very important thing
to keep in mind
far away almost 600 times further away
than Proxima Centauri our closest
neighboring star even if you could
travel say one percent of the speed of
light you wouldn't get there anytime
soon
at this speed you could whip around
Earth in just over 13 seconds but to get
to Kepler 69c well that would take you
about 238
000 years to even make this trip
possible you'd need a super Advanced
hibernation pod you know you don't want
to grow too old and die before you could
even get to your destination
am I right
well hibernation technology that could
help you sleep for over 200 000 years
doesn't exist yet but hey this is what
if anything's possible
by the time your ship makes its arrival
any life that may exist on Kepler 69c
today could evolve or Advance into
something entirely different
think about it this way 300
000 years ago humans were just beginning
to create stone tools and Spears
and look at you now making a trip across
the Galaxy
looking back at the planet you left
behind who knows what changes would
happen to our human civilization during
your trip
no matter what it's way too late to turn
around now
based on the planet's distance from its
star we know that Kepler 69c receives a
similar amount of sunlight as Venus
and despite being more massive than
Earth it has a relatively low density
all this means is that instead of metals
this rocky planet is made of silicate
and carbonate minerals
that could make things a little
complicated you see with all these
minerals in the crust Kepler 69c could
have a really thick atmosphere and to
make matters worse this atmosphere would
be composed mostly of carbon dioxide
oh did you choose the wrong super earth
to travel to
yeah if Kepler 69c is anything like
Venus it would be a pretty hot planet
all because similar to Venus its clouds
would trap the Heat and create an
extreme greenhouse effect
Kepler 69c's atmosphere would be caught
in an endless cycle of getting thicker
and hotter
but nobody said this world should be
habitable for you oh no once you took
off your helmet you'd instantly melt and
suffocate
like I said life on this planet would be
completely different from what you'd
imagine
as you made your approach you'd find
surface temperatures as high as
475 degrees Celsius and the atmospheric
pressure would be over 90 times that of
Earth at sea level it would be like
being 900 meters deep in the ocean
except you'd be on dry land
with conditions like this you'd likely
not find anything resembling an ocean
here just like on Venus the high
temperatures would boil away all the
water
whatever life you could potentially
encounter on this planet it would need
to be able to survive in these brutal
conditions
or it would have to exist somewhere else
besides the surface
one place you could Discover Life on
Kepler 69c would be up in the clouds
around 50 kilometers up temperatures
would be much much cooler they would
range from about 30 to 70 degrees
Celsius and with its low density this
planet could have a surface gravity that
would be just over 70 percent of what's
found on Earth
this weaker gravity could allow life
forms to thrive in the sky where Kepler
69c is most hospitable
life could just be floating freely in
the atmosphere
this would be another way in which this
planet could have far more in common
with Venus than with Earth
probes around Venus have picked up
traces of a gas that could be a
potential sign of life phosphine
if you discovered phosphine in
kepler-69c's atmosphere it could be the
result of bacteria that don't require
oxygen to survive but be ready to hold
your nose this smelly gas has an odor
similar to decaying fish
on Earth the bacteria that produce
phosphine often live in swamps or
Wetlands but on Venus or kepler-69c this
bacteria could exist in the thick
oxygen-less atmosphere itself
so in the end you may have traveled a
very very long way to find the smallest
and stinkiest of Life Farms
now on the upside you've just discovered
extraterrestrial life
now why not see if there are any other
hospitable planets in this neighborhood
you know with more advanced life forms
like on Kepler 22b
but that's a story or another
what if
[Music]